The world is now
one big small town.
But withinthat
virtual town square,
there are tiers
of relationships,
degrees of intimacy,
and everyonedeserves a
different amount of you,
a different side.
Now, where those
boundaries lie
is upto you.
I try to wait 48 hours
before posting and sharing
because that way I
can be present
inprivate with
the people I love
before calculating
how I'm going to
publicly position it.
And postwith purpose.
Before I share, I
ask myself: Why?
What's the purpose?
And most importantly,
how doesit serve
the people I love?
Because cultivating a
private life is precious.
It's sacred.
Itsvalue is inherent in
what you don't share.